There was a horrifying scene
in the skies
over Dallas yesterday
when two vintage
airplanes collided in midair.
The accident happening
during an air
show sending flaming
wreckage plummeting to the groun
as spectators were watching.
We do want to warn you,
the video
may be disturbing to some viewer
A Boeing B-17 flying
fortress and a Bell P.
63 King
Cobra collided and crashed
at the wings over Dallas
Airshow Saturday.
According to the Federal Aviatio
Administration,
in a press conference Saturday
afternoon, Hank Coates, presiden
and CEO of the Commemorative Air
told reporters about the cruise
during the World War Two demonst
The B-17
normally has a crew of four to f
That was what was on the aircraf
And the 63 was a single piloted
fighter type aircraft.
I can tell you that that
it was normally crude.
I cannot release the number of p
on the manifest
or the names of the manifest
until I'm released to do so by t
The Allied Pilots
Association, the labor
union representing American Airl
pilots, has identified two pilot
and former
APA members
among those killed in the collis
The APA said former members Terr
and Len Root
were among the crew members on t
Flying Fortress.
Our hearts go out to their famil
friends and colleagues, past
and present, their tweets said.
The NTSB is launching
a go team to investigate
Saturday's midair collision.
A tweet from the NTSB on Saturda
evening said in part,
No spectators or others on
the ground were reported injured
The debris field from the collis
includes the Dallas
Executive Airport grounds,
Highway 67, and a nearby strip m
It is worth noting that the FAA
does require
these stunts to be approved
ahead of time.
One expert
tells us, though,
that even as safety measures
have been put in place, over the
there's still tremendous risk
when performing these complex
and dangerous moves. Here's Mary
When tragedies
happen at air shows,
the FAA has to reevaluate
whether this should be allowed.
Because remember,
even though
the regular federal aviation rul
don't apply, the FAA does approv
License aerobatic flights,
license,
these dramatic maneuver
events and air shows,
and they have to permit these ai
So the FAA does over
time has increased requirements
and safety measures.
But in the end, you're flying
extremely complicated maneuvers.
You're doing aerobatic flight.
You're supposed to be licensed t
so or to do fly information.
You have the special certificate
Dynamic maneuvering, you know,
rocking your wings dramatically.
You know, from left to right, et
Right.
That all has to be approved by t